[Applause]
it's a really interesting thing because
the fight that most people are talking
about you even mentioned it afterwards
and i thought you were very graceful to
john you said
i think jon jones is the the best ever
in mixed martial arts and people talk
about the jon jones fight
i from what he tweeted it didn't seem
like he
wanted to fight you it seemed like he
wanted to make
money getting knocked out by you
[Laughter]
because he didn't say let's fight he
just goes uh show me the money
yes maybe because uh has talked about
this fight
he had talked about the fight before and
uh
didn't see the money you know
listen i think john john has been there
for
so long time and uh
has had many title fights but i think if
this fight happened it's going to be the
biggest for him
such as for me of course you know
i believe that this is going to be a
mega fight it's
a huge fight so and uh
we are doing this in order to one day
with expectations when they have this uh
payday you know they may get paid
and if something come together to like
make this
mega fight so it's just
uh normal to ask or to have it payday
because you it's not like you're asking
if
you're asking something for something
irrational you're just acting
asking for your own small card
from the the revenue that the fight that
you're making
gonna generate uh basically if you are
the man
we stand as a good good good and make
the fight bigger
i think it's right in his position
hmm yeah it's what when you go into a
fight with
with jones let's say you're gonna fight
jones what do you see
uh are your advantages over him right
now
listen i have i think the best way for
me to approach
um this fight is not to think
uh it's it's just to think that uh
i have already even given uh
disadvantage over john jones
i think this would be the best way for
me to
get ready to uh prepare myself
uh into this fight so what would be some
of those things that you think i need to
i'm always improving now what do you
improve
if you want to fight jon jones what do
you got to work on
everything as i said
i'm going to work on everything i'm
going to keep working on my trapping i'm
going to keep
working my uh resting and i'm gonna keep
working on my striking
you know i'm gonna
keep working on my conditioning as well
so i'm gonna work on everything i'm
gonna keep working
on my uh mental game
or the aspect that if uh if guys can
request
are gonna be working on that because we
are talking of
someone who has been there like for such
a long time
i mean even though he's very john and i
we are almost the same age but he's been
here
uh even in the usa almost 10 years
before me
and he's been in the sport uh
for his entire life so the experience
that he has over me
he still there's such a big gap between
our experience that i need
to compensate that we just will work
so i don't think like right now uh i
have the right to stay there and
think that i have an advantage on
something
overcharging wow and uh over any one of
anyway what about a potential fight
with derrick lewis again you guys think
that you would do that
yeah that would be the i mean uh in the
normal wall
uh if he wasn't above the joint jupiter
fire i think that directly with five
will be the perfect
fight for me next uh first of all
i have a rematch we have decided that we
never really
did it neither for us neither for the
fans you know i love digging him
but not because i didn't fight well not
because i didn't
uh it was better but just because
i didn't fight so we have this i have
this thing that i need to fix
back um and he's a
legit contender right now and
my goal as a chance here now is to keep
the heavyweight division moving
you know the heavyweight division has
been
stuck for so long so
and i was evicting a direct system of
that
so i decided to like do my own
do away differently so now that your
champ you're saying you're going to be
active
i'm going to be active as i said i will
be ready by july august
i'm raised this fight twice this year
again
wow i love it i love it now
i don't know if you've been following i
know that you're obviously a fan of
boxing have you been following this
fight between
jake paul and ben askren
well i heard about that but following i
don't
think no
[Laughter]
i don't think it's something that it
much can
cut my attention at at that point
you know i follow the heavyweight
division
[Applause]
mostly
you